[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور تاتينا من مخيم
عين الحلوه من محيط المخيم وهو مخيم للذين
الفلسطينيين في لبنان مع استمرار ترقب
التاكيد على وقت اطلاق النار
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد تحذير قاده الانقلاب في النيجر من اي
تدخل عسكري فرنسي باريس تنفي وجود نيه لها
للتدخل عسكريا وتقول ان عوده الرئيس
المحتجز ممكنه واشنطن تصف الوضع في النيجر
بالمتغير والكشف عن اتصال بين رئيس
الاركان الامريكي وقائد الجيش في النيجر
الاسبوع الماضي وموسكو تدعو الى العوده
للنظام
اشتباكات رغم الاعلان عن وقف لاطلاق النار
في مخيم عين الحلوى جنوبيه لبنان النائب
اللبناني اسامه سعد يقول للجزيره انه تم
الاتفاق على التحقيق لتحديد من اغتالوا
قائد الامن الوطني الفلسطيني في صيدا
الفصائل تحذر من عمليات التهجير وميقات
يتهم جهات خارجيه باستخدام لبنان لتصفيه
حساباتها
اوكرانيا تعلن عن اتفاق لتصدير الحبوب عبر
الموانئ الكرواتيه مع استمرار توقف تنفيذ
مبادره التصدير عبر البحر الاسود و واشنطن
تشكك في قدره الاتفاق الجديد على استيعاب
متطلبات السوق وتؤكد استمرار دعمها
الاستئناف المبادره
في السودان معارك ضاريه في العاصمه
الخرطوم طائرات الجيش تقصف مواقع للدعم
السريع الجنوبيه الخرطوم انفجارات تهز ام
درمان اثر اشتباكات بالمدفعيه والاسلحه
الثقيله
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الاشتباكات في مخيم عين
الحلوه للاجئين الفلسطينيين جنوبيه لبنان
حيث اعلنت منظمه الاندرويد مقتل احد عشر
شخصا حتى الان ونزوح الفي شخص اثراء فشل
جهود وقف اطلاق النار استطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في رايكم ما هي الانعكاسات
المحتمله للمواجهات المستمره في مخيم عين
الحلوه وقد جاءت النتيجه نتيجه التصويت
جاءت كما يلي 31% قالوا ان الانعكاسات
تتمثل باتساع نطاق الاشتباكات في حين قال
نحو 33% ان الانعكاسات هي تاثر الوجود
الفلسطيني في المخيم جراء التهجير بينما
راى 36% ان التاثير سيكون انحسار
الاشتباكات
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا
[موسيقى]
نبدا من النيجر حيث اتهم متحدث باسم قاده
الانقلاب وزير الخارجيه القائمه باعمال
رئيس الوزراء هاسمي مسودو بتوقيع وثيقه
تسمح لفرنسا بتنفيذه هجمات على مقر
الرئاسه بهدف تحرير الرئيس المحتز محمد
بازوم كما اتهم ايضا قائد الحرس قائد
الحرس الوطني بتوقيع وثيقه مماثله
مع سياساتها في البحث عن سبل ووسائل
للتدخل عسكريا في النيجر عقدت فرنسا
بتواطؤ بعض النيجيريين اجتماعا في مقر
الحرس الوطني للحصول على التراخيص
السياسيه والعسكريه اللازمه ووقع حسوم
مسعود كرئيس للوزراء بالوكاله وثيقه يفوض
فيها فرنسا بتنفيذ ضربات داخل القصر
الرئاسي من اجل اطلاق سراح رئيس الجمهوريه
المحتجز محمد بازوم وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه كاترين كولونا نفت مع وصف ته
بتهامات الانقلابيين بشان تدخل عسكري
فرنسي في النيجر واضافت ان عوده رئيس
النيجر ممكنه وضروريه وانه يجب ان يعود
نظام الدستوري بسرعه مشيره الى ان محاوله
روسيا الاستفاده من الوضع في النيجر
احتمال غير مستبعد وقالت وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه ان الاولويه بالنسبه لبلادها هي
ضمان امن رعاياها
وكان الرئيس الانتقالي في تشاد محمد ادريس
ديبي قد التقى في نياميه عاصمه النيجر مع
كل من الرئيس محمد بازون في اول ظهور له
منذ الانقلاب ورئيس المجلس العسكري الحاكم
الجنرال عبد الرحمن تيامي والرئيس السابق
محمد يوسف واكد ان هناك معهم سبل حل
الازمه التي تعيشها النيجر
اما في واشنطن فقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه
انها ما زالت تقيم الاوضاع على الارض
مشيره الى ان الوضع ما زال متغيرا وقالت
ان الرئيس الاركان الامريكي اجرى الاسبوع
الماضي اتصالا مع قائد الجيش في النيجر
وخلال انقلابات شهدتها بعض دول غرب
افريقيا تكرر نفس المشهد حيث هاجم
متظاهرون مصالح فرنسيه ورفعوا اعلاما
روسيه ولم يخفي المتظاهرون التعبير عن
عداء متنام في المنطقه لفرنسا قوه
الاستعمار السابقه وصاحبه النفوذ الواسعه
هناك في المقابل يبدي المتظاهرون ترحيبا
بروسيا من خلال رفع علمها
مشهد يتكرر في النيجر بعدما شاهد مماثله
في دول مجاوره حرق العلم الفرنسي ومهاجمه
مصالح فرنسيه وفي المقابل رفع علم روسيا
يؤشر المشهد الى وجود صراع بين فرنسا
صاحبه النفوذ القديم في غرب افريقيا
وروسيا التي زاد اهتمامها بالمنطقه في
الفتره الاخيره بعد اعلان انقلاب رحب به
قائد مجموعه فاغنر
المختفي عن الانظار قال في تسجيل منسوب
اليه انها لحظه تاخرت كثيرا للتخلص من
المستعمر حسب تعبيره لم يشير بيجين الى اي
دور لفاغنر فيما يجري في النيجر لكن
وبالنظر الى انتشار قوات المجموعه في
المنطقه تتخوف الدول الغربيه من استغلالها
الوضع الحالي لدخول نيجر ايضا توجد قوات
مجموعه فاغنر في افريقيا الوسطى وليبيا
ومالي ويعتقد ان لها ادوارا مختلفه في دول
افريقيه اخرى
وتعتبر الدول الغربيه فاجنر وسيله روسيا
لنشر نفوذها في افريقيا ولم يصدر عن
السلطات الروسيه بعد تمرد قائد المجموعه
ما يشير الى تغيير او الغاء لدورها في
القاره الافريقيه في جوار مالي لا يخفي
النظام الذي تسلم السلطه بعد انقلاب
العسكري تعامله مع فاجنر في اغسطس السنه
الماضيه اكملت فرنسا سحب ثلاثه الاف جندي
بطلب من السلطات الماليه نقل نصفهم تقريبا
الى النيجر فيما يقدر عدد قوات فاغنر هناك
بالف مسلح ثم طالبت السلطات التي تسلمت
السلطه في بوركينا فاسو بعد انقلاب عسكري
ايضا فرنسا بسحب 400 من القوات الخاصه
امام هذا الوضع اصبحت النيجر الى جانب
تشاد اهم بلدين يستقبلان قوات فرنسيه يوجد
في النيجر حاليا 1500 جندي فرنسي هذا
الوجود سيصبح مهددا اذا لم يتم التراجع عن
الانقلاب وساءت علاقه باريس مع من
ولا يقتصر الاهتمام بالنيجر على فرنسا فقد
اقامت الولايات المتحده قاعده جويه
لاستخدام المسيرات في شمال شرقي النيجر
ونشرت 1200 جندي هناك انطلاقا من موقعها
الاستراتيجي تكتسي النيجر اهميه قصوى
لفرنسا والولايات المتحده في حربما على
الجماعات المسلحه في منطقه الساحل ولذلك
فارغامهما على المغادره سيشكل انتكاسه
كبيره تزداد قسوتها اذا اصبح موطئ قدم في
هذا البلد ايضا
معنا من العاصمه الغنيه اكره الدكتور
ايمانويل الكويسي النينجا الخبير في
الشؤون الافريقيه الدكتور مانيويل
بدايه كان هناك حديث عن اتصال من قائد
الجيش الامريكي بقائد
الجيش في النيجر الى اي مدى الولايات
المتحده تلعب دورا حاسما فيما يجري وما قد
يجري في نعمه
لست متاكدا اذا ما كان يمكننا ان نسلط
الضوء على اهميه هذا الموضوع من هذه
الزاويه ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لديها قاعده عسكريه اساسيه وتواجد عسكري
في النيجر ولكن بالنسبه الى التقييم
الحالي وبالنظر من
داويه
المصالح الخاصه بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه طبعا القاعده تفيد الولايات
المتحده في مكافحه الارهاب ولكن بالنسبه
الى التواجد العسكري الامريكي وما اذا كان
يساعد في احلال الاستقرار
والديمقراطيه في النيجر هذا مشكوك بامره
للغايه ولذلك نتحدث عن مسالتين منفصلتين
الامريكيون والفرنسيون في النيجر هم في
النيجر لم صلحتهم وليس لمصلحه الشعب نعم
ولكن هم في كل الاحوال لهم موقف واضح
بتاييد الرئيس محمد بازوم موقفهم هذا الى
اي مدى هو مؤثر فيما قد يجري في النيجر
لقد دعموا الرئيس بازون ولكن في الحقيقه
ليست هذه المساله المهمه ما نحن بحاجه
اليه هو ان يعمل الرئيس محمد بازوم لمصلحه
شعب النيجر وليس لمصلحه شعبي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اذا
على سبيل المثال اي حكومه لا يمكنها او اي
شعب لا يمكنه ان يقبل ان تعمل الحكومه
لصالح دوله اخرى على اي حال نحن بحاجه الى
عمليات ديمقراطيه في النيجر ترقى الى
تطلعات شعبي النيجر وطموحي الشعب ليس اسمح
اسمح لي دكتور اسمح لي انا لا اسالك اسمح
لي لا اسالك عن الطموحات والاحلام ما اريد
ان افهمه منك كخبير في شان الافريقي هو
مدى ان تا ثير النفوذ الامريكي والفرنسي
الداعم للرئيس محمد بازون بغض النظر عما
يجب ان يكون سؤالي لك الى اي مدى هذا
سيؤثر فيما قد يحدث في موقف الجيش في تغير
الامور في عوده بازوم من عدم عوده بازو
ان بزوم لن يعود الى سده الرئاسه لان
بازومي ينظر اليه من قبل شعب النيجر على
انه شخص يعمل لمصلحه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وفرنسا وليس لمصلحه شعب البلد
واعتقد ان الاسره الدوليه يتعين عليها ان
تفهم ذلك يجب ان لا تقود العمليات
الديمقراطيه مصالح المجتمع الدولي حسب
باي مقياس انت تقول ان الشعب لا يريد
بازوم في حين بعزوم هو رئيس منتخب ومنقلب
عليهم عسكريون غير منتخبين يعني ما الذي
نعتمد عليه في القول ان الشعب لا يريد
بازون وهو الذي انتخبه
في الحقيقه الديمقراطيه لا تتوقف فقط على
كتابه مستند او وثيقه وايضا على تصويت او
انتخابات او اقتراح الديمقراطيه ترتبط
بالعمل
والامن والتعليم
والحفاظ على كرامه الشعب في البلاد اذا ما
ذهبنا الى انتخابات
واخذنا بعين الاعتبار مشاعر الناس هذا شيء
ولكن اذا ما لم تحترم كرامه الناس في اي
بلد هذه ليست بالديمقراطيه ولذلك يجب ان
نتوخى الحذر عندما يتعلق الامر
بفرض العمليه على الشعوب الافريقيه في
بوركينا فاسو في مالي في بلدان اخرى في
النيجر الان
الرب يقول شيئا مختلف ويتعينوا على
المجتمع الدولي ان يقبل ذلك دعونا نطرح
السؤال كيف لنا فيه النيجر ان نحصل على
اعمال
ووظائف وتعليم الى اخره اذا ما قمنا بذلك
الديمقراطيه سوف تحصل ولكن في كل اربع
سنوات الاقتراع في صندوق لكي ياتي شخصا ما
ويسيء استخدام الموارد هذه ليست
بالديمقراطيه شكرا جزيلا من الدكتور
الكويسي الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه
[موسيقى]
الى لبنان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره
باستمرار الاشتباكات في مخيم عين الحلوه
للاجئين الفلسطينيين الجنوبيه البلاد
وقالت وكاله العمر وان الاشتباكات ادت الى
مقتل احد عشر شخصا واصابه اربعين بينهم
عضو في فريق الوكاله وكانت الاشتباكاته قد
تجددت قبل ظهر اليوم حيث استخدمت فيها
الاسلحه الرشاشه والقذائف الصاروخيه رغم
اعلان فصائل فلسطينيه واحزاب لبنانيه
التوصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
هذا ودفعت الاشتباكات المسلحه التي شهدها
المخيم عددا من سكان المخيم للنزوح باتجاه
مدينه صيدا المجاوره واكدت وكاله الغوث
وتشغيل اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الانفرار
اكثر من الفي شخص من المخيم
وقد شيع جثمان قائد الامن الوطني
الفلسطيني في منطقه صيدا ابو اشرف
العرموشي ونقل من احد مستشفيات مدينه صيدا
الى مخيم الراشديه في منطقه صور الجنوبيه
وشارك في التشييع عدد من مسؤوليه حركه فتح
ومناصريها اضافه الى ممثلين عن فصائل
منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه في لبنان
هذا واكد النائب في البرلمان اللبناني
اسامه سعد توصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق
النار في مخيم عين الحلوه للاجئين
الفلسطينيين وقال في مقاله في لقاء مع
الجزيره قال ان الاتفاق تضمن ايضا تشكيل
لجنه للتحقيق في اغتيال المسؤول الامني في
المخيم ابو اشرف العرموشي
تشكيل لجنه تحقيق هالجنه بدها تروح تحدد
مين المسؤول عبر يعني
معطيات بدها تتوفر الى زائد انه كل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بدها
تقدم شو عندها معلومات لهذه اللجنه لحتى
نحدد مين مسؤول وبالتالي حتى ما يتكرر هذا
الموضوع لازم تاخذ اجراءات فوريه بتسليم
المجرمين المرتكبين هذا الاغتيال للسلطات
اللبنانيه
وكان امينو سري حركه فتح في لبنان فتحي
ابو العرضات قال ان الحركه ملتزمه بوقف
اطلاق النار في مخيم عين الحلوه وهناك
توجه للتهدئه في المخيم واكد ابو
العارضيات على وجوب التوصل الى معرفه من
سماهم المجرمين والقتله وتسليمهم الى
العداله اللبنانيه كي تستقيم الامور على
حد تعبيره واوضح ان لدى الحركه حركه فتح
خيوطا تتعلق بما وصفه بجريمه اغتيال قائد
الامن الوطني في صيدا ابو اشرف العرموشي
اما القوى الاسلاميه في مخيم عين الحلوه
فاكدت تقضى على ضروره وقف اطلاق النار
وسحب المسلحين وتشكيل لجنه تحقيق لكشف
المتورطين وجددت القوى الاسلاميه حرصها
على امن واستقرار مخيم عين الحلوه وجوارح
من جهه قال ممثل وحركه حماس في لبنان احمد
عبد الهادي ان الاحداث المؤسفه في مخيم
عين الحلوه تشكل خطرا على القضيه
الفلسطينيه وتهدد قضيه اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين في لبنان
في الاثناء قال رئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال
اللبنانيه نجيب ميقاتي ان هناك وقفا جديا
لاطلاق النار في مخيم عين الحلوه لكنه لفت
الى وجود جهات خارج الاتفاق ما فتئت تخرقه
بسببك مستمر حسب تعبيره واكدا خلال تراسه
جلسه لحكومته رفضه استخدام ساحه اللبنانيه
لتصفيه ما سماه حسابات خارجيه على حساب
بلاده واشار ميقاته الى ان الجيش اللبناني
يقوم بواجبه لمعالجه الوضع في مخيمة عنده
حلوى مؤكدا ان ما يجري مرفوض كونه كونه
يكرس المخيم كبؤره خارجه عن سيطره الدوله
وفق قوله
من محيط المخيم عين الحلوه في صيدا انضم
الينا مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي ايهاب
الى اين وصلت الامور في المخيم يوم محيطه
نعم الاتصالات مع المجموعات
المتقاتله داخل حي الطوارئ في مخيم عين
الحلوي للاجئين الفلسطينيين مستمره في
محاوله لانهاء هذا الاشتباك المستمر منذ
اكثر من 24 ساعه بين حركه فتح ومجموعات
متفرقه تضع نفسها في خانه الاسلاميين
الاشتباكات نجمع عنها حتى اللحظه تسعه
قتله واكثر من 60 جريحا خصوصا وانها تجري
في منطقه مقتظه بالسكان ويعد حي الطوارئ
احد المناطق الاكثر اكتظاظا في المخيم
ومخيم عين الحلوه يضم نحو 54 الف لاجئ
فلسطيني في المخيم
يعني حصلت حالات نزوح من حي الطوارئ
باتجاه الاحياء الاخرى الاكثر امنا والى
المدينه تولى التوكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطيني للاونروا نقل
الذين نزحوا من المخيم الى بعض المدارس
التابعه لها في محاوله لوائهم لفتره مؤقته
حتى يتسنى للقوى والفصائل الفلسطينيه وقف
كامل لاطلاق النار اطلاق النار عمليا هذه
الليله تراجع بشكل كبير حدته
باتت جدا محدوده وهو متباعد زمنيا بعض
القذائف الصاروخيه تطلق بين الحين والاخر
ثم يتبعها رشقات من الرصاص لكنها بقيت
محدوده جدا في مشاهدناه طوال ساعات هذا
النهار الذي شهد اشتباكات هي الاعنف في
المخيم منذ سنوات
ادى هذا الامر الى تدمير عدد كبير من
المنازل واصابه ممتلكات المواطنين في حي
الطوارئ والاحياء الاخرى ووصلت عمليه
اطلاق النار الى مدينه صيدا التي عمليا
شلت الحركه بمعظمها في احيائها الداخليه
وايضا في الاحياء القريبه من المخيم وقطعت
القوى الامنيه الاوتوستراد الشرقي للمدينه
الذي يربط جنوب لبنان بصيدا ومن ثم ببيروت
وايضا الحق
الرصاص الطائش اضرارا بممتلكات المواطنين
في القرى المحيطه بمخيم عين الحلوه
الان اطلقت
قذيفه صاروخيه ربما يتبعه بعد قليل رشقات
ناريه ولكن هذه الليله اتسمت بالهدوء
العام
القوى الفلسطينيه تريد تثبيت وقف اطلاق
النار باسرع وقت ممكن لكن رئيس الحكومه
كان تحدث عن مجموعات لا ترغب باحلال
التهدئه ووقف اط النار الذي قال رئيس
الحكومه اللبنانيه انه جدي وايضا الفصائل
الفلسطينيه والقوه الاسلاميه تريد
بتثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
وتتخوف هذه القوى والفصائل من ان تتمدد
الاشتباكات الى احياء اخرى في المخيم مما
يؤدي الى تداعيات كبيره على اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين في هذا المخيم وقد يكون له
ايضا تداعيات ليس على محيط المخيم
اللبناني فحسب وانما ايضا على المخيمات
الفلسطينيه الاخرى من محيط المخيم عين
الحلوه في صيدا براسه الجزيره ايهاب
العقدي شكرا جزيلا لك
مشهد نزوح مئات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين من
مخيم عين الحلوه الجنوبيه لبنان الجراء
الاشتباكات رصدته
في هذا التقرير
تصلي بمدينه صيدا يختزل المشهد معاناه
عشرات العائلات الفلسطينيه النازحه حملوا
ما تيسر لهم من متاع وفروا من مخيم كان
شاهدا لعقود على مسار لجوءهم الشاق فمع
عوده الاشتباكات الى ازقه مخيم عين الحلوه
تجددت ماساه الالاف من سكانه
وعوضا عن هدهدة الام للطفله التي ولدت قبل
ايام كان القصف في انتظارها
جبت اولادي واجبته وما جبت لهم ولا حليب
ولا عمرك
لاكثر من سته عقود تنقل سمير بين مخيمات
اللجوء كفيف ومقعد وبحاجه ماسه الى الدعم
الطبي لا ما في
يعني اي مشكله كل واحد
واذ يستمر توافد اللاجئين الفلسطينيين وسط
مخاوف من استمرار الاشتباكات تحاول جمعيات
الاهليه تقديم ما تيسر من دعم لهم
نسبه اطفال العاليه وخاصه كمان عنا نسبه
مسنين مرتفعه شوي الاحداث الامنيه التي
شهدها مخيم عين الحلوه تشكل فصلا جديدا من
فصول عدم الاستقرار الذي يعيشه سكان
المخيم منذ عقود وهذا المشهد حلقه من
حلقات الواقع المرير الذي يعيشه اللاجئون
الفلسطينيون في لبنان على كافه المستويات
الامنيه والمعيشيه والاجتماعيه
وعلى وقع الاشتباكات المتقطعه تجري
محاولات حل الازمه ووقف اطلاق النار
فثمت اجماع من الفصائل الفلسطينيه على
ضروره وقف الاقتتال مساع تهدف الى سحب
فوري للمسلحين وانشاء لجنه تحقيق لكشف
ملابسات التطورات الامنيه التي شهدها
المخيم ومحاسبه الضالعين فيها هدف اعرب
الجميع الفصائل والاحزاب الفلسطينيه
واللبنانيه عن ضروره التوصل اليه في اقرب
فرصه لتجلب المخيم وسكانه ومحيطه دوره عنف
تبدو عبثيه بالنسبه لكثيرين كارمنج خضار
الجزيره من محيط مخيم عين الحلوه
هذا وتتشعب الخريطه السياسيه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه الفاعله في مخيم عين الحلوه
للاجئين الفلسطينيين الجنوبيه لبنان وهو
المخيم الاكبر من حيث المساحه وعدد السكان
الواقع الاقتصادي والاجتماعي للاجئين
والفصائل الفاعله في المخيم نتابعه في هذا
التقرير
يبعد قرابه ثلاثه كيلومترات عن صيدا
وقرابه 67 كيلومترا عن الحدود مع الاراضي
الفلسطينيه يسميه اللاجئون الفلسطينيون في
لبنان عاصمه الشتات الفلسطيني اسسه الصليب
الاحمر الدولي عام
1948 لايواء اللاجئين من مدن شمال فلسطين
تغيب الارقام الرسميه لعدد سكانه تشير
تقديرات لوجود قرابه 70 الف نسمه في
المخيم
وقدرت الاونروا عددهم بنحو ثمانيه واربعين
الفا عام 2019
بينما تشير تقديرات اخرى الى ان عدد سكانه
يقترب من 54 الفا جميعهم يعيشون على مساحه
لا تتجاوز كيلو مترا مربعا واحدا
يشترك مخيم عين الحلوه مع جميع مخيمات
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في لبنان بترد بالغ
للبنيه التحتيه وغيابها في كثير من
الاحيان غياب الخدمات الصحيه الملائمه
والكافيه لاعداد اللاجئين تدني المستوى
التعليمي للسكان حيث تنشط فقط مدارس تابعه
لوكاله الاونروا منع دخول اي مواد بناء
رغم تهلك المنازل ويمنع على اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين اصلا تملك اي منزل او عقار
كما يمنعون من اي حقوق مدنيه او اجتماعيه
ومن العمل خارج المخيمات بعشرات المهن
والاختصاصات بينما ترتفع نصب البطاله داخل
هذه المخيمات
يتولى الجيش اللبناني الامني عند جميع
مداخل مخيمات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
لبنان دون الدخول اليها بينما تعمل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في الداخل
تتشعب الخريطه السياسيه لهذه الفصائل في
عين الحلوه تمتلك حركه فتح تنظيما واسعا
في المخيم وما يعرف بالتيار الاصلاحي في
الحركه بقياده محمد عيسى الملقب باللينو
والمحسوب على القيادي السابق في فتح محمد
دحلان وتوجد ايضا الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير
فلسطين والجبهه الشعبيه القياده العامه
وحضور وازن لحركتي حماس والجهاد الاسلامي
كما شهد المخيم خلال العقدين الاخيرين
نموا لحركات تصف نفسها بانها حركات
اسلاميه بعضها تم حله وبعضها الاخر ما زال
مستمرا
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا حيث اعلن وزير الخارجيه
ديمترو كوليبا اتفاق بلاده مع كرواتيا على
امكانيه استخدام الموانئ الكرواتيه لتصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه وياتي القرار بعد
انسحاب روسيا من اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب من
الموانئ الاوكرانيه وكانت وزاره الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه قالت ان الضربات الجويه
الروسيه دمرت ما يقدر بنحو 180 الف طن
متريا من محاصيل الحبوب الاوكرانيه في
غضون تسعه ايام هذا الشهر
وتعليقا على الاعلان الاوكراني بشان
الاتفاق مع كرواتيا قالت المندوبه
الامريكيه في مجلس الامن الدولي لندى
توماس ان البحر الاسود يظل الطريقه الاكثر
فعاليه لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه واكدت ان
البدائل لتصدير الحبوب لا يمكنها استيعاب
الساعه نفسها التي تستوعبها موانئ البحر
الاسود
لم اسمع على وجه التحديد عن استخدام
الموانئ الكرواتيه لكنني اعلم ان اوكرانيا
كانت تبحث عن بدائل لموانئ البحر الاسود
الان استخدمت بعض هذه البدائل بالفعل
لكنها لا تستطيع استيعاب كميه القمح التي
تحتاج للوصول الى السوق والتي يمكن ان
توفرها مبادره البحر الاسود نحن ندعم تلك
الجهود البديله ولكننا سنواصل ايضا دعم
جهود الامين العام والاخرين لايجاد طريق
للمضي قدما لاستئناف مبادره الحبوب عبر
موانئ البحر الاسود
سيناريو استخدام الموانئ الكرواتيه لتصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه يتطلب نقل الحبوب ربما
برا عبر الشاحنات او القطارات الى دول
الجوار ومنها الى كرواتها ثم الى البحر
المتوسط وبقيه دول العالم لكن يعيق ذلك
القدرات المحدوده للنقل البري على نقل
كميات كبيره مقارنه بالنقل البحري اضافه
الى الكلفه العاليه وكان الطريق تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه بموجب اتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب مع روسيا ينطلق من موانئ اوكرانيا
على البحر الاسود مثل اوديسا
وشرنامورسك
ومنها الى مدينه اسطنبول التركيه عبر
الفسفور حيث يتم تفتيش السفن قبل توجهها
الى بقيه دول العالم
من لندن معنى تمثي اش الخبير الاقتصادي
سيد تمثي
مدى وجاهت ان يتم تصدير الحبوب عن طريق
كرواتيا كما يقول الرئيس زيلينسكي
في الحقيقه كما ذكرتم هذا يساعد بعض الشيء
ولكن المشكله مرتبطه بقدرات الطرق
المحدوده وسكك الحديد المحدوده ان الموانئ
على البحر الاسود كانت تستوعب حوالي 3.5
مليون طن من الحبوب بالشهر للصادرات ولكن
لسوء الحظ سكك الحديث
يمكنها ان تستوعب مليون طن والطرق حوالي
650 الف الى 800 الف طن وبالتالي نصف قدره
الموانئ على البحر الاسود اذا سوف تساعد
بعض الشيء ولكنها لن تحل المشكله الاساسيه
ان موانئ البحر الاسود مهمه وايضا الدانوب
ظهر الدانوب يمكن ان يكون لديه قدرات
كبيره كذلك وبالتالي هل يوجد خيار امام
اوكرانيا يعني الجميع يتحدث عن صعوبه هذا
الامر وكونه ليس ربما بديلا تماما عن
البحر الاسود ولكن هل يوجد خيار لدى
اوكرانيا غير ان تق وم بهذه الخطوه
المشكله هي مرتبطه ليس فقط بان روسيا
تحاصر البحر الاسود ولكن تدمر البنى
التحتيه الاوكرانيه اذا تدمر كل الاليات
التي تسمح
بنقل الحبوب الى السفن بالاضافه الى
الموانئ في نهر الدانوب والتي يمكن ان
تشكل تشكل بديلا كما سبق واسلفت ولكن
روسيا تدمر هذه القدرات لذلك من الصعوبه
بمكان ان تستخدم هذه السبل مع تدمير البنى
التحتيه لذلك يتعين على اوكرانيا ان تعتمد
على البنى التحتيه من طرق وسكك حديد وكما
اشرنا القدرات محدوده والتكلفه مرتفعه
الخبيره الاقتصادي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
حددت المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل يوم 12 من
شهر ايلول سبتمبر المقبل موعدا للنظر في
التماسات مقدمه لالغاء التعديل القانوني
الذي يمنع القضاه المحكمه العليا من الغاء
قرارات او تعيينات للحكومه او اذرعها
التنفيذيه وقد اثار التعديل الذي اقره
الكنيست الاسبوع الماضي احتجاجات واسعه في
اسرائيل حيث اعتبره رافضوه انقلابا على
نظام الحكم ومساسا سافرا باهم اسس
الديمقراطيه والفصل بين السلطات في
اسرائيل حسب تعبيرهم
هذا ونقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن وزير
الدفاع يؤف جلند قوله ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
جاهز لاداء المهام الموكله اليه لكنه قد
يعاني من تراجع في جاهزيته على المدى
البعيد وشارك جلند في جلسه استثنائيه
للجنه الخارجيه والامن البرلمانيه عقدت في
مقر وزاره الدفاع لمناقشه تداعيات اعلان
الاف الجنود والضباط وقفه تطوعهم في صفوف
الجيش احتجاجا على تمرير التغييرات
القضائيه
التعديلات القضائيه وما يحدث في اسرائيل
كان جزءا من سجال بين اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو عن هذا المشهد
نشر الكاتب والصحفي الامريكي المعروف
توماس فريدمان مقالا الاسبوع الماضي في
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وتوماس ينضم الينا
الان من واشنطن اهلا بك
قلت ان اسرائيل معرضه للانهيار من الداخل
ما لم يحدث تدخل من الرئيس بايدن
هذا ما قلته في مقالك ما هي المعطيات التي
بنيت عليها هذا التقدير
عثمان ما اقوله من محاججه هو ان تحالف
اليمين المتطرف الذي اشكله رئيس الوزراء
ابنه نتنياهو له هدفين ومشروعين هدى
اولهما
اضعاف النظام القضائي الاسرائيلي وقدرته
على مراقبه قرارات الحكومه وثانيهما هو
تفكيك مشروع اوسلو والتمهيد لضم اسرائيل
المباشر للضفه الغربيه ومن اجل ان يحقق
ذلك يحاول اضعاف النظام القضائي تمهيدا
لضم الضفه الغربيه مما اشرت اليه يعني انت
قلت ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن هو
الوحيد هو الوحيد القادر على انقاذ
اسرائيل اليوم ضمن اجراءات سردتها لكن
في رايك الى اي مدى قد تستمع اليه حكومه
بنيامنه
الاجابه حتى الان هم الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تجاهلوه تماما وعندما حاولوا الاستحواذ
على النظام القضائي طبعا اي رئيس امريكي
لا يمكننا نفعل الا قدرا معينا عندما
يتعامل مع وضع داخلي في اسرائيل ويتعامل
مع ذراعي الدوله التشريع عفوا التنفيذي
والقضائي ونتنياهو قد تجاهل الرئيس فيما
يتعلق بالجانب الاستراتيجي الامر قد يختلف
في قضايا القيم المشتركه بعد ان فعل كل ما
يستطيع نعم قلت في مقالك ان تمرير مشروع
تعديلات القضائيه سيتسبب في كسر الجيش
الاسرائيلي
وسيقوض ليس فقط القيام المشتركه بين
اسرائيل وامريكا بل المصالح الامريكيه
الاستراتيجيه في الشرق الاوسط ان بلغت
الامور هذا المستوى ونتنياهو ماض في
مشروعه ويتجاهل اداره بايدن كما ذكرت للتو
ما هو السيناريو
المحتمل للتصرف الامريكي
طبعا انا ساخذ نظره الى الوراء اقول لا
اتوقع المزيد من الخطوات الامريكيه فيما
يتعلق
بالتعديلات القضائيه لكن اما فيما يتعلق
باي صفقه استراتيجيه في نطاق النطاق
المصاحفرجيه مع السعوديه او مشروع انا عشت
حوالي خمس سنوات في بلدين في الشرق الاوسط
اولا في لبنان ثم ثانيا في اسرائيل هذان
البلدان حقيقه لديهما سمتان مشتركتان
كلاهما صغير جدا في المساحه لكن لديه تنوع
كبير جدا في السكان هم هم بلدان صغيران
لكن متنوعان بشكل كبير عندما يكون هناك
بلد صغير بهذا الحجم و بهذا التنوع
الاسلوب الوحيد لحكمه من خلال ان تعيش
وتدع الاخرين يعيشون لا غالب ولا مغلوب لا
منتصر ولا مهذب لكن حقيقه اننا نتنياهو
قرر ان يحكم ليس على هذا الاساس ليس على
اساس لا غالب ولا مغلوب بل صار في الاتجاه
المختلف هذا ممكن ان يؤدي الى انهيار
اسرائيل كما انهار لبنان عندما عندما رفضت
السلطات الحاكمه او المتنفذه ان تعيش وفق
مبدا التعايش اذا على المدى البعيد لا
اقصد ان اسرائيل
يصبحوا مثل هنغاريا وتركيا وغير لكن سيكون
مثل لبنان المنهار وهذا هو التهديد الذي
تواجهه اسرائيل على المدى البعيد اذا ما
اراد بلد ان ينتحر كما فعل لبنان او كما
تريد اسرائيل الان لا يمكن لاي قوه اجنبيه
ان تفعل المزيد لهم
اقترحت في في مقالك ان يوجه بايدن وزراء
الخارجيه والدفاع والخزانه والتجاره
والزراعه
الامريكيين كذلك المدعي العام وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه ان يوجههم للاتصال
بنظرائهم الاسرائيليين لاخبارهم بانه اذا
ماذا مضى نتنياهو للامام دون اجماع فان
ذلك سيفتت المجتمع الاسرائيلي والجيشه هل
تم الاستماع لهذه النصائح وفق تقديرك هل
تعتقد ان الرئيس بايدن قد يوجه وزرائه
لنقل هذه الرساله
ياهو هو اكبر الرهينه في الشرق الاوسط
وانا عندما كنت
مراسلنا مصر ايتها الكثير من حالات خطف
الرهائن هذه اكبر حاله خطف
رهينه لكنها من صنع يديه هو
اسس تحالفا من اليهود متطرفين
ومتصهنين من اجل الحصول على السلطه لتفادي
محاكمه تهم بفساد وجهه اليه وقال لهم لا
يهمكم الامر انا اتولى زمام القياده هو لا
يملك زمام القياده هو حتى لم يعد في
المقعد الامامي ناهيك عن قياده المقوى في
المقعد الخلفي هذا ليس اتهاما هذه حقيقه
في اللحظه التي تحالفه يهد
بترك الحكومه واسقاط الحكومه اذا لم ينصت
لهم لا هو يقول لهم اي خدمه يبيع ويسارع
الى انفاذ رغباتهم لانه يريد التشبث
بالسلطه اما لتفادي الادانه او اذا ما تمت
ادانته ان يحاول مقايضه ادانته بشيء من
النفاذ من العقاب هو اذا الرهينه الولايات
المتحده تؤكد دائما انها تؤيد حل الدولتين
في رايك ما هو مصير حل الدولتين في ظل هذه
الاجراءات المتسارعه وسياسه هضم الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
والحديث عن دوله واحده يهوديه
محل الدولتين هو في حاله من العنايه
المركزه ويعيش على الانعاش من الناحيه
الطبيه هو الحل الوحيد لكن علينا ان نرى
اذا كانت هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ليست
شريكا مناسبا لاي حل دولتين على الولات
المتحده تحاول ان التوصل الى
اتفاقات امنيه مع السعوديه مقابل تطبيعي
علاقاته السعوديه مع اسرائيل وتقديم
تنازلات للفلسطينيين ربما قد نجد انفسنا
امام وضع اخر هذا ربما هو الامل الوحيد
الذي يمكن ادخاله ان نرى تحقيق حل
الدولتان عثمان ان يكون هذا ضمن نطاقي
صفقه امريكيه سعوديه تستطيع
ادخال المزيد من الحوافز الى الصفقه
المزيد من العصا والجزرات
من تنامي العمليات ضد اسرائيل في الضفه
الغربيه اي مؤشر قد يعطيه فيما يتعلق
بتصاعد سياسات اليمين وتحكمها في السياسات
الامنيه استراتيجيه الامنيه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه
هذا ينظر لك انه لا يوجد حل عسكري
لاسرائيل بالمناسبه لا يوجد حل عسكريا
للفلسطينيين كذلك هم ايضا لا يبدو انهم
يحققون اي تقدم ربما هم يجب ان يستفيدون
من حركه الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل ويقومون
بعمليه
احتجاج غير عنفيه او سلميه وطبعا عن قتل
اسرائيليين هنا وهناك كل كم اسبوع مره لن
يؤدي الى نتيجه كلا الطرفان يحتاجوا الى
اعاده تفكير تماما في موقفه بالعوده الى
حديثك عن الخطر بانهيار اسرائيل هذه
التعديلات القضائيه والتمسك بها الى اي
مدى تؤدي الى انقسام عميق وحقيقي في
المجتمع
الاسرائيلي
وتهدد حتى يعني ثبات المؤسسه الامنيه
سمعنا كثيرا على سبيل المثال الالاف من
جنود الاحتياط الذين يرفضون القيام الان
بالاعمال المتعلقه بالتطوع للجيش
اذا قلت اسرائيل فقط
ستنجح وفعلت ذلك فقط مع تنوع المجتمع على
اساس ان تعيش وتدعى الاخرين يعيشون لا
غالب ولا مغلوب طبعا انت لديك القدس وانا
لدي تل ابيب لك هذا وانا لهذا وهكذا لكن
هذه الحكومه الجديده
اسست مبادئ جديده في الحوكمه واحدها
ينطبق كما فعل بعض الديكتاتورين في
افريقيا وهو القول بانه هذا هذا ليس وقتكم
لمشاركتنا الطعام اذا لا احد سياكل
ابتعدوا عن مفهم عن مفهوم عش ودع الاخرين
يعيشون الى هذا المفهوم الجديد هذا لم
ينجح في لبنان ولن ينجح في اسرائيل ليس مع
هذا التنوع السكاني الكاتب الصحفي
الامريكي توماس فريد من شكرا جزيلا لك
للحديث الينا في الحصاد على شاشه الجزيره
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث قال مصدر عسكري في الجيش
السوداني للجزيره ان الطائرات الحربيه
قصفت اهدافا لقوات الدعم السريع في منطقتي
المسعوديه وزياده جنوب مدينه الخرطوم وذكر
المصدر ان قصف الطائرات للمنطقتين ادى الى
تدمير رتل من السيارات القتاليه لقوات
الدعم السريع فيما افاد مراسل الجزيره
بوقوع اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في مناطق متفرقه
من مدينه ام درمان ما ادى الى انفجارات
وتصاعد الدخان من المنطقه كما حلقت طائرات
حربيه تابعه للجيش السوداني في اجواء مدن
الخرطوم الثلاث بالتزامن مع اطلاق
المضادات الارضيه التابعه للدعم السريع
نيرانها تجاه الطائرات
في الاثناء قررت سلطه الطيران المدني
تمديد اغلاق المجال الجوي للبلاد حتى
الخامسه عشر من اغسطس باستثناء رحلات
المساعدات الانسانيه والاجلاء واتهم الجيش
السوداني قوات الدعم السريع بقصف منطقه
ابو ادم في الخرطوم بشكل عشوائي ما ادى
الى مقتل طفل واضاف الجيش في بيان له ان
وحداته هاجمت مجموعه بالدعم السريع في وسط
درمان واشتبكت معها واوقعت خسائر في
صفوفها
[موسيقى]
لقي شخصان على الاقل مزرعهما في ضواحي
العاصمه الصينيه بيجين جراء امطار غزيره
تشهدها المدينه وضواحيها وقد تم اجلاء
اكثر من 31 الف شخص من منازلهم مع وصول
بقايا اعصار دكتور الى العاصمه
اخيرا وصل الاعصار دكتوري الى بيجين
مصحوبا بامطار وصفت بانها الاكثر غزره منذ
اعوام
في هذا الحي الواقعي في الضاحيه الغربيه
من المدينه
فاض النهر ليغمر الشوارع بالمياه والطين
ويجرف بعض المركبات التي كانت في طريقه
مشاهد القت الرعب في قلوب السكان
عمري 70 عاما لم ارى قط مثل هذا المطر
الغزير في حياته لقد تساقط لفتره طويله
قلق اضيف الى مخاوف السكان خصوصا بعد
اعلان اكتشاف جثتين لمواطنين غرقا في احد
الانهار عندما جرفهما السيل واجلاء الاف
مواطنين الذين غمرت المياه منازلهم
قولوا السلطات الصينيه ان الامطار التي
تشهدها العاصمه
وضواحيها حاليا هي الاكثر منذ عشر سنوات
ونلاحظ خلفنا هنا مخلفات عاصفه امطار هدات
للتو لكن الضرر الاكبر كان في الضواحل
القريبه من المناطق الجبليه
ففي تلك المناطق تتجمع مياه الامطار بين
الجبال التي حين ينهار جزء منها تنساب
كميات كبيره من المياه فجاه لتجتاح كل ما
يعترض طريقها وتترك خلفها خرابا ودمارا
صوت
الفيضان القادم من الجبل رهيبا جرف الكثير
من السيارات والناس لا احد يستطيع السيطره
على الكوارث الطبيعيه اعتقد ان البلاد
يمكن ان تتعامل مع هذا الامر بشكل افضل
مكتب الارصاد الجويه في العاصمه الصينيه
ذكر ان كميه الامطار التي هطلت خلال يومين
تعادل تقريبا
متوسطه الامطار لشهر يوليو كله
كما سجلت الصين خلال هذا الصيف درجات
حراره مرتفعه وهي احوال جويه يقول العلماء
انها تفاقمت بسبب تغير المناخ في العالم
ناصر عبد الحق الجزيره بيجيم
[موسيقى]
في فقره في المتابعه اليوم نتوقف عند
الاجواء السوريه احتكاكات وقعت بين القوات
الامريكيه والروسيه فما الذي يحدث هناك
السؤال يفرضه تكرار حوادث الاحتكاك بين
طائرات حربيه وروسيه هناك خلال طلعات جويه
يفترض انها خاضعه لما يعرف ببروتوكول تجنب
المواجهه الاتفاق الذي بدا العمل به قبل
سنوات بين واشنطن وموسكو يشمل الابلاغ
المسبق عن مهمات سلاح الجو لكل منهما في
سوريا فضلا عن التزام مسافه التحليق الامن
لمعنى اي تصادم لكن منذ شهر مارس الماضي
زادت وتيره ما يقول الجيش الامريكي انها
مضايقه طيارين روس لمقاتلات ومسيرات
امريكيه خلال تنفيذها مهمات للتحالف
الدولي
لمكافحه تنظيم الدوله لاسيما في الجزء
الغربي من سوريا في المقابل تتهم روسيا
بشكل دوريه الولايات المتحده بارتكاب
مقاتلاتها خروقات مماثله في السماء
السوريه فضلا عن انتهاك قواعد السلامه
وتسير ما تصفه لكن غير قانونيه فوق منطقه
التنف الواقعه على المثلث الحدودي بين
سوريا والعراق والاردن تزايد وتيره حوادث
الاحتكاك بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا في
الاجواء السوريه يثير مخاوف من تكثيف
الصراع الذي زادت حدته بين الجانبين على
خلفيه الحرب في اوكرانيا عقب تلك الحرب
خلصت روسيا عدد قواتها في سوريا وتراجع
عدد مواقع انتشارها من 132 موقعا الى
105 مواقع فقط لكن الروس يحتفظون بقواعد
عسكريه انشؤوها في اكثر من محافظه سوريه
فضلا عن سيطرتهم على قاعدتي حميمين وترطوس
في المقابل ضاعفت الولايات المتحده اخيرا
قواتها في سوريا وزادت عدد مواقعها هناك
الى 30 موقعا معظمها في الشمال والشرقي
البلاد بمحافظتي الحسكه ودير الزور وقد
زودت الولايات المتحده اذن
عدد قواتها في سوريا
بمنظومه هاي مارس كذلك
من باريس ينضم الينا الدكتور زياد ماجد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه في باريس اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور
كيف يمكن النظر الى هذه الاحتكاكات في
الصوره
الكبير
اللي
العلاقه المتوتره تاريخيا بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده بمعنى هل هي فقط
في سوريا ام لها علاقه كما قلت بالصوره
الكبيره بين المجاهدين هي اكتشك على علاقه
بالصوره الكبيره وكما تفضلت حضرتك خلال
التقديم
البروتوكول الذي كان قائما في سوريا والذي
كان على الطرفين احترامه متى ينتهك بشكل
دوري
وهناك ما يبدو انه رغبه عند الطرفين لرفع
محدود لمستوى التوتر ذلك ان لكل طرف طبعا
في سوريا وفي مواقع اخرى حسابات مختلفه
ويمكن ان تكون متناقضه امريكا لا تريد ان
تفرض روسيا حلها في سوريا وهي لذلك توسع
من حضورها
لديها مساله استراتيجيه هي الحدود
العراقيه السوريه وروسيا في المقابل رغم
تراجع اولويه الشان السوري بسبب حربها على
اوكرانيا انما لا تريد ان تظهر علامات ضعف
في الساحه السوريه لذلك هذه الاحتكاكات
يمكن ان تستمر وان ينتهك البروتوكول بشكل
اضافي لكن اعتقد ان اطارها يبقى مضبوطا كي
لا يفتح صراعات مباشره او المزيد من
التوترات الولايات المتحده ذي ماذا برايك
زادت عدد
مواقعها وقواتها ايضا في سوريا بشكل ملحوظ
بعد حديث دار في نهايه عهد ترامب عن
احتمالات الانسحاب الامريكي اظهر بايدن
انه لا يريد ان يترك هذا الملف لكي تديره
روسيا وحدها ضمن تعاونها مع ايران ومع
تركيا في مفاوضات استانا ومتلاها ثم ان
هناك المساله الخاصه بالحدود العراقيه
وبتحركات القوى المواليه لايران عبر
الحدود لا تريد امريكا ان تتخلل الان عن
هذه الورقه السوريه اذا صح التعبير في
مواجهه موسكو بعد اندلاع الحرب الاوكرانيه
صارت تعتبر ان الجبهات مع موسكو كل ما كان
لوشنطن حضور فيها كل ما حسنت من شروط
الوصول يوما ما الى حل تفاوضى مع الروس في
اكثر من ملف لذلك الان موضوع روسيا عفوا
موضوع سوريا عاد مجددا الى الاجنده
الامريكيه من زاويه امنيه فيما يخص روسيا
ولكنه ايضا
ارتباط بالحضور التركي بعد ان استعادت
تركيا زخمه علاقتها مع حلف شمال الاطلسي
وهناك بالتاكيد حقول النفط شرق سوريا وكل
مساله اعاده هيكله القوات الكرديه
وازاله التوترات بينها وبين بعض القوى
العربيه في شرق الفرات او في الشرق السوري
لذلك هناك مجموعه اهداف لكن بلا شك عدم
ترك سوريا لروسيا وحدها او للحلف الروسي
الايراني في اداره ثلثين الاراضي السوريه
تقريبا دعما للنظام السوري يعني باختصار
هناك سؤال كبير حول ترك الولايات المتحده
اصلا لهذه المنطقه كما قيل منذ سنوات
هل هذا تغير الى حد ما
لم يتغير تماما بلا شك هناك تراجع امريكي
عن الاهتمام بكل ملفات المنطقه او عن
اعتبار ان الشرق الاوسط هو ضمن جدول
الاولويات الامريكي لكن الحرب الان وعوده
التوتر الشديد في مناخ العلاقات الدوليه
اعاده لبعض مناطق الشرق الاوسط اهميتها
الاستراتيجيه امريكيا منها سوريا منها
العراق منها ايضا البحث في اعاده صياغه
علاقات جديده مع عدد من الانظمه العربيه
التي اظهرت وتحديدا دول الخليج قدرتها على
المناوره على الابتعاد قليلا عن واشنطن
والتقرب الى بكين وموسكو لذلك هناك ربما
اعاده صياغه امريكيه لعلاقات جديده شكرا
جزيلا من باريس الدكتور زياد العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه الامريكيه في باريس
نهايه الحصاد الليله شكرا والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]